docteur qu'un vice président de
l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
dr weiss bonsoir bon on réglera pas
l'histoire du masque une fois pour
toutes
mais quand même je vous fais entendre
docteur new de l' agence de santé
publique du canada
ensuite doctorat à horacio arruda de la
santé publique du québec sur cette
question qui revient et qui repart qui
revient doiteau ou non porter le masque
quand on sort de chez nous on écoute
pour vous tous des médecins génisses en
chef dé toutes les provinces et
territoires sont à crocs et une autre
mesure supplémentaire
c'est quelque chose on peut s'en servir
mais c'est pas comme une recommandation
ce qui est indiqué les danses etc en
rien le port du masque fait maison doit
être là pour remplacer les autres
mesures pour dr weiss ce n'est pas une
recommandation de l'agencé de santé
publique du canada
c'est une suggestion douce presque en
disant si vous sortez puis vous voulez
absolument apporter un pendant à porter
un
mais n'oubliez pas les autres règles
d'hygiène pas ça vous protège repos ça
peut peut-être protéger les gens si vous
êtes prêt du latex
comment vous voyez ça moi d'abord comme
une situation évolutive alors il est
clair que le masque tout seul n'est pas
une panacée
c'est à dire qu'un masque doit s'ajouter
aux autres mesures de distanciation
social de lavage des mains d'essayer
notamment de ne pas se toucher le visage
mais ceci étant dit dans les cultures
asiatiques le masque est porté depuis
très longtemps
et lorsqu'on compare les cours des pays
asiatiques singapour ou des villes comme
hong kong ou même dans certains endroits
de chine par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé en occident il est clair que la
différence en porter un masque et ne pas
porter un masque de façon universelle
semble avoir eu d impact
en plus des autres mesures dont qu'est
ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on veut pas
le problème numéro un c'est qu'on n'a
pas assez masse pour tout le monde et il
faut le dire là qu'on est on est on est
capable de fournir des masques à tout le
monde
regardez les masques pour les
travailleurs de la santé lorsqu'ils sont
en contact avec les gens très à risque
ceci étant dit ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas utiliser le masque si on peut
l'utiliser dans la population générale
si vous devez aller vous promener si
vous devez allez faire votre épicerie
vous avez la capacité de couvrir votre
bouche de couvrir votre nez ou d'avoir
un masque même artisanale elle un tant
soit peu c'est c'est pas une mauvaise
chose
loin de là pourquoi ils seront pas des
masses on parle des masses parce que si
on est affecté
et lorsqu'on parle on y met des
gouttelettes et ses gouttelettes leur
peuvent aller affecter d'autres
personnes donc en mettant m as trouvé
une barrière pour prévenir l'infection
des autres c'est vraiment dans ce sens
là que ça marche plus que dans le sens
contraire où il ya peut-être eu un
certain effet mais qui va être limité
donc la réponse c'est ce qu'on doit ou
pas porter un masque
la réponse est dans l'état actuel des
choses je pense qu'un masque va être une
solution supplémentaire utile et vous
avez vu que même dans les pays
occidentaux
aux etats unis en france les gens sont
en train maintenant tranquillement de
glisser vers la suggestion à la
population générale de porter une
protection pour améliorer si vous voulez
la pl est là là là et de la propagation
du virus dans la population pour
protéger plan le soulignera jamais assez
les autres et non pas soi même parce que
docteur arruda rétais pas de répondre
depuis dix jours sur ce n'est pas utile
pour nous parce qu'on se met les doigts
dans le visage
on a compris sa maison par des autres en
public ça peut nous protéger de nos
gouttelettes à nous oui tout à fait il
ya probablement une certaine protection
si pour nous mêmes c'est une barrière
hamas mais la protection maximale qu'on
va avoir c'est si on empêchait tout les
gens qui seraient porteurs
asymptomatiques du virus ou pas très
malade et qui sortent quand même de
mettre leurs sécrétions donc en
dispersion dans l'air que les autres
vont respirer ça va aussi améliorer
l'état des choses on sait pas c'est pas
négligeable il faut pas non plus du
revers de la main dire les masses ça
sert à rien c'est pas bon il faut aussi
dire que les masques actuelle on en a
pas et comme on est excité mais il faut
aussi les utiliser là où
on mutile en a le maximum de rendement
c'est aussi malheureux de dire mais
c'est ça qu'il faut dire c'est pas un
cas ce point détaillé en a assez il y en
a pas assez
si vous vivez dans un endroit où les
masques étaient en abondance
exceptionnelle et tout le monde avec des
masques à leur disposition ce serait pas
compliqué de dire autant vous sortez
vous portez et joints des gens de plus
en plus avec des foulards ou des trucs
de motorola d un truc de coton bon ben
ça aide un peu je présume pour pas que
les gouttelettes aille trop loin
tout à fait à l'écouter là il faut
essayer de faire comme on dit flèche de
tout bois
alors dans le contexte actuel va écouter
on va on va faire ce qu'on peut faire
pour réduire au maximum la truck and bus
là alors je le répète mesdames et
messieurs c'est une suggestion de santé
canada de la direction de la santé
publique du canada et non pas une
directive
une suggestion oui ça peut pas nuire si
vous allez à l'extérieur vous elle est
que vous devez peut-être vous approcher
trop malheureusement déjà ça peut être
une protection mais pour les autres
davantage que pour soi je pense qu'on a
on se répèterait trousses on ajoutait
des choses docteur j'ai pensé à vous en
fin de semaine il ya quelqu'un qui
m'envoyait un article sur celui qui a
inventé le lavage des mains le docteur
ignace philippe c'est mal weiss le
connais si vous aviez nous on n'est pas
apparenté ma grand mère est née à vienne
mais sa mise à part on n'est pas
apparenté tous les deux mais en effet il
n'ya jamais levé c'est un médecin
viennois du la fin du 19ème début du 20e
siècle qui avaient ce permis de montrer
que le lavage des mains et est quelque
chose qui a permis justement de réduire
les infections de façon très important
il avait fait ça dans des étangs dans
les groupes d'obstétrique
mais il avait démontré que les femmes
les sages femmes qui se laver les mains
entre les accouchements bain à avait
beaucoup moins d'infections chez leur
part turrian qu'un groupe de docteurs
qui ne se lavait pas les mains entre les
accouchements et donc il avait démontré
que le lavage des mains
ah pas très important dans la santé des
femmes après l'accouchement et ça a
commenté le plasma du lavage des mains
est ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'on ne le croyait pas à l'époque que
l'on peut traiter de fou est lui presque
morts de folie de tristesse parce que
les gens ne le croyais pas que ça
fonctionnait le lavage des mains mon
dieu s'il voyait le débat actuel souvent
médecine c'est comme ça les gens nul
n'est prophète en son pays
les premiers bars les premières
personnes qui ont commencé à favoriser
la vaccination
on les a pris aussi pour des fous mais
j'parle de jenner et des jantes en louis
pasteur a toujours ses débuts il y avait
beaucoup de sceptiques dans tout ça vous
savez non j'ai une question d'un enfant
parce qu'il reste pas beaucoup de temps
mais je vais je veux absolument prendre
celle là ll numéro 6 il a 12 ans j'ai 12
ans dit il je vis avec mes parents et ma
soeur ma mère travaille en clinique et
en ch à celle d où des cas de l'accord
et 19 ont été confirmés malheureusement
oui en a beaucoup dans les sièges celle
de mon père et immo immuno supprimés est
ce que ça veut dire que ma mère va
devoir vivre ailleurs pendant toute la
part des mines ou même jusqu'à on se
trouve un vaccin pour cimenter kent oui
c'est très raisonnable et c'est très
bien d'avoir finalement une certaine
inquiétude mais l'idée évidemment c'est
de minimiser les contacts jusqu'à un
certain point quand on est malade et
c'est surtout de bien se protéger quand
on travaille c'est à dire si on a des
contacts avec des gens qui sont
potentiellement malades et j'espère que
maintenant dans tous les sièges celle d
il ya des masses temps en disponibilité
de l'équipement médical de protection
c'est aussi d'essayer par exemple de ne
pas porter le même linge quand on
travaille là bas donc de porter des
habits de d'hôpital et quand on arrive à
la maison vin de ne pas porter les mêmes
habits d'essayer de se laver les mains
en entrant à la maison etc
et puis il faut comprendre aussi que
l'immunosuppression c'est très variable
ça dépend pour quoi on est kimi no
supprimés si c'est quelqu'un qui a une
greffe c'est quelque chose site c'est
quelqu'un qui prend un petit peu de
stéroïdes parce qu'il fait un peu
d'asthme c'est autre chose
donc le terme immunosuppression il faut
faire aussi attention bon dr weiss vous
avez l'air bien
je viens en forme si on continue on
continue en avril difficile peu après on
verra le soleil c'est ça alors on dit on
dit en avril ne te découvre pas d'un fil
est bien là vous savez c'est il faut pas
ceux des confits ne refile exactement ce
qu'il a dit le premier ministre
merci dr weiss à demain merci et bonne
soirée